janik and gawkway refusing to be a part
of the minnesota vikings not really
although for all we know behind the
scenes he said get me the hell out of
here
if so it worked yannick and gawkway
traded the baltimore ravens
by the vikings what they ultimately did
they gave up a second round pick
next year and a conditional fifth round
pick in 2022 to getting gawk away from
the jaguars right before the start of
the season
they get a third round pick from the
ravens and a conditional
fifth round pick in 2022 from baltimore
and peter is a practical matter you're
looking at a high second round pick that
the vikings have given up
to the jaguars to get in gawkway and now
what's likely going to be a
low third round pick back maybe a
two-round drop
as a practical matter for the minnesota
vikings from the
failed yannick and gawkway experiment
they do avoid six million or so in
salary
for ngakue that's money that can be
banked and cap space that could be
carried over to next year when the cap
may be as low as 175 million
but the vikings seem
to be folding the tents and it makes me
wonder who else from that roster is
going to be available in trade this year
as the vikings accept reality they ain't
making it to the postseason
they're not going to get full value for
yannick and gawkway they may as well
pull the plug who else
may they pull the plug on what's
you know there's a couple interesting
things about what baltimore has done in
my opinion
if you look at the two players on their
team
who were jaguars last year they traded
the 157th pick in the draft in the 2020
draft
to bring in calais campbell he is one of
the very best and maybe it'll only last
for a year or two we don't know
but he's one of the very best two-way
uh defensive lineman in football right
now you know
stop the run and rush the passer and now
they get yannick and gawkway for what
probably will be
somewhere around the 90th pick in the
2021
nfl draft so imagine you get two guys
with that level of talent
for a low three and a low five
it's it's quite honestly uh you know
eric decosta the gm of the ravens
done an absolutely terrific job because
i think he
understands the weaknesses of teams that
he's dealing with
right now what you look at with calais
campbell
you knew he was an older guy the jaguars
say we're rebuilding for the future
we'll take what we can get for him and
so decosta go gets a guy of distressed
value even though he's still a really
good player
and then almost the same thing with
yannick and gawkway
what do the minnesota vikings want they
want to be in a better cap
position when the cap plummets to 175
million next year
mike i think this could be the start
of a really really interesting trading
season
okay and though there's there's a
there's more than a week to go
before the trading deadline which is
november 3rd
i think you're going to see a lot of
teams try to off
load salary because they want to be in a
better cap position
in 2021 and 22 not necessarily to get a
lot better
and of course they want the draft pick
but it's more important right now for a
lot of teams
to do something about their aching
swollen
salary caps and you know the other
reality as well and this is something
that i now
challenge myself to have a firm answer
on but i've been
i've been pondering this question of the
interplay between the trade deadline and
the covet 19 protocols
which are getting more and more
stringent all the time
when's the sweet spot to pull off a
trade the trade deadline itself
i don't know that we're going to see
trades then i think the practical
deadline is coming up
next week not necessarily tuesday
november the third so get ready for some
more activity because if it's going to
happen it's got to happen
soon because if mike we should you have
to we should really explain that
we should really explain that could i
have a go at explaining that because i
think
it's really important for people to
realize
about why even though the trade deadline
is november 3rd
for all practical purposes if you're the
baltimore ravens
you really needed a yannick and gawkway
in your camp last night or very early
this morning for this reason
you've got to test negative uh on your
coven test for
five consecutive days before you can
join a new team so in that way
the baltimore ravens have a bye this
week so if ngakwe gets in and tests
negative
today friday then saturday sunday monday
tuesday
that means at the start of the practice
week
for one of the ravens biggest games of
the year
against the pittsburgh steelers uh a
week from
sunday you're going to have calais
campbell on campus
in meetings understanding this new
defense he's got to learn
for a full five days before he plays in
his first game
because look if you make the trade for
him next tuesday he's not playing for
you
against the pittsburgh steelers you
needed to make the trade
now so that he can get his coven uh
protocol out of the way so he can start
playing in games for you
and my assumption would be also that you
can't even take your physical until
after you get through the covet protocol
so if the deal is going to fall apart
you want to know it falls apart so you
still have time to trade it maybe to
someone else because we know how these
physicals can be
one team may fail a guy another team may
pass a guy that's another reason
to move now so you know that the deal is
done and everything's official
everything goes through
before you're at the point where the
window closes but that is a very real
concern it was a perfect time for the
ravens and the vikings to do this deal
because the vikings are in there by
the ravens are in there by and they'll
have yannick and gawkway when they
emerge
from there by hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports